hello and thank you for joining us for
this virtual poster session I'm shocked
Mooji but product development scientist
at fluid I'm and today I'd like to take
you through our poster titled expanding
the capabilities of the Macs part direct
immune profiling assay for site soft
systems with additional markers and
customization of the analysis model in
max power path setter so I'd like to
give you a brief outline of our poster
and invite you to take a closer look at
it - ants I'd like to introduce you to
the max of our direct Indian profiling
system and the workflow it entails and
then go into the materials and methods
and the results for a small scientific
validation study we did with verifying
that the additional markers we add as
I'll discuss worked physiologically
accurately and then we'll discuss the
conclusions so I'd like to introduce you
to you to site of technology which is
stands for cytometry by time-of-flight
which is a mass cytometry technology
which uses multiple tagged antibodies
for highly multiplex profiling of single
cells it's important to note that each
of these antibodies is conjugated with a
distinct isotopic mass which means that
it does not suffer from the same signal
spillover issues as experienced by
fluorescent cytometry and does not
require compensation therefore we can
design panels comprising gate greater
than 50 markers for comprehensive and
in-depth immune profiling studies in
this particular poster i'll be taking
you through a 44 marker panel that we
built around the max card direct immune
profiling assay what is the max power or
direct inion profiling assay it is a
ready to use dry format of 30 pre
titrated markers that are provided in a
single tube for immunity no typing of
human whole blood or PBMCs as shown in
the figure on the top the process is
very straightforward a user simply adds
the specimen into the tube stains it
according to standard staining protocols
acquires it on a mass cytometer and then
can upload that data into the paired max
power path setter software which will
automatically analyze the data and
cluster into immune cell populations and
cell subsets of interest
this makes the max
direct immune profiling sa ideal for
longitudinal studies especially in the
context of studying immune responses in
infectious diseases and has actually
already been applied for Kobe 19
research and several other infectious
disease models so these are the 30
markers that are included in the max for
direct immune profiling assay these 30
markers include common phenotype in
markers for T cells B cells monocytes
and granulocytes in human whole blood or
PBMCs and actually also include markers
for further subsetting of these immune
cell types into their smaller subsets
importantly as also shown in this table
there are 14 additional channels
available for users to customize this
panel and add in markers of interest to
them to really provide a come up with
comprehensive panels to study the immune
system I'd also like to tell you that
the 14 open channels that were shown in
the previous table exhibit minimal
signal spillover into in a sample
stained with the 30 markers really
suggesting that a user when they add a
marker in here can result in the
generation of high-quality data which
will allow for high resolution analysis
of their data as well in this particular
poster I will demonstrate that we added
14 antibodies as tabulated over here
these 14 antibodies that we added
included high-value functional targets
such as PD one Tim 3-digit amongst
others and we also incorporated
phenotypic markers such as for myeloid
arise suppressor cells the markers being
C D 11 B and C D 33 amongst the other
markers shown in the table over here
these antibodies can be obtained from
the fluid and catalog of reagents or may
be custom conjugated using our labeling
kits or even using the fluid I'm
provided in-house service for custom
conjugation I can show this to you in
the form of a of a wheel this is the 30
marker panel over here highlighting the
open spots as the blank white boxes and
in this particular case what we did is
we filled this in with these 14
antibodies
which are now shown in the wheel so we
made a comprehensive 44 marker immune
phenotype in panel which was then tested
amongst these samples so to talk about
the samples I'd like to discuss the
materials and methods so what we did in
this particular experiment is that we
had PBMC samples from three healthy
donors and three donors diagnosed with
rheumatoid arthritis and what we did is
we either rest of the PBMC cells
overnight or pH a stimulated them
overnight the following day the cells
were stained according to this staining
procedures outlined in the max part
direct immune profiling assay these
samples were then acquired on a Helios
mask cytometer
which results in the output of an FCS
file that FCS file was then uploaded
into the Mac's part pad setter software
and in this particular case we actually
modelled the data we updated and
modified the Mac's of our path set our
software model to really highlight the
expression patterns of the 44 marker
panel I'd like to showcase the what max
of our paths that our software it does
so here we're showing a sense a plot
which is actually a dimensionality
reduction tool which can take the
markers built into the max of our direct
immune profiling essay and cluster it
into immune cells and there's cell
subsets as you can see each of these
clusters can be into the cd4 t-cell cd8
t-cells myeloid cells B cells and
they're smaller subsets such as memory
such as their memory memory phenotypes
as well on the Left we're looking at the
30 marker clustering and on the right
we're looking at the clustering with the
44 markers and well it's important to
note in the dashed circle over there is
that by the addition of the extra
markers for further stratification of
the myeloid cell cluster x' into the MDS
C's or the myeloid derived suppressor
cells we can get greater resolution
amongst the cluster to further resolve
these populations we can also look at
Sensei plots as a neat tool to visualize
the expression patterns of each of these
markers on the immune cell phenotypes on
the immune cells that were interested in
and here we're looking at from the top
left off sporty two-digit expression on
unstimulated or PHA stimulated cells as
showcased over here what I'd like to
direct you to here is
when we look at the expression pattern
of each of these functional markers
what's important to note is that the
expression patterns align with what is
known biologically and is
physiologically accurate for example we
can look at eye cos expression which is
centered around the T cell clusters but
not expressed on B cells or we can look
at digit expression which is showcased
in particularly memory T cells but not
even within the naive T cells indicating
that the staining patterns were
observing are in line with what is known
scientifically we can also then look at
the expression patterns of the
phenotypic markers that we added into
this panel and again we can validate
that these expression patterns align
with what is biologically known for
example CD 33 expression is observed in
the myeloid clusters and CD 2 expression
for example is shown in the T and NK
cell clusters but not on the myeloid
cells suggesting that we're getting
specific staining of the immune cells
that we should be getting to move on to
the results in the first case we're just
looking at the expression of five of
these functional markers on the total
cd4 T cell subsets as identified by
their memory phenotypes divided into
naive central memory effector memory or
terminally differentiated effector T
cells what I'd like to highlight to you
here is that within the healthy donors
and the rheumatoid arthritis samples
designators RA we observe and indicate a
trend to increased ox40 expression on
the cd4 T cell subsets which is
something that has been published in the
literature as well so we are getting
correct results over here and then we
can also visualize the expression of
several other markers on the cd4 T cell
subsets we can also then look at the
expression patterns on the unstimulated
versus the PHA stimulated cells and if I
direct you to figure 6c over here we're
looking at expression of PDL 1 and ox40
within cd4 t-cell subsets and observe
that within the RA samples we the RA
samples cd4 T cells actually exhibit a
reduced capacity to upregulate these two
functional markers upon PHA stimulation
suggesting that these cells as has
already been noted in the literature are
already immune activated and therefore
cannot increase or up regulate the
expression of these markers to such a
I level I'd like to also showcase that
what max for paths that are does is it
actually analyzes automatically analyzes
this data and produces a report what
we've done in this case over here as is
shown in the red boxes is we've actually
added 27 additional parameters to be
showcased on this report so a user can
actually modify this report so
immediately and rapidly call out cell
counts and frequencies of the functional
markers and their expression in
particular cell subsets that they might
be interested in for example we are
showcasing expression of ox40 pd-1 on
cd4 T cells and its subset we can also
look at a fast expression on B cells etc
so this is a highly customizable model
where the users can actually modify it
to immediately see the parameters that
they are interested in max pop etcetera
also produces what's called progression
plots where we can within an immune cell
type actually monitor the expression of
particular immune cell markers across
the cell subsets so shown over here on
the top left on the top panel we're
actually looking at the cd4 t-cell
subsets and we're looking at the
expression patterns of these markers
that we added so for example we can note
that the cd7 expression is highest on
the naive cells and the and
progressively decreases as we get
towards the terminally differentiated
effector cells in the bottom half of
that figure we can we're actually
looking at the myeloid cell populations
and we can actually see that CD 33 and
CD 99 expression for example is highest
on the classical monocytic population
compared to the other non classical or
intermediate monocytic populations so
this is just to highlight that the user
can get an immensely good visualization
tool and also a quantifiable tool when
they're analyzing their data by max
carpet setter so to summarize I just
like to showcase or tell you that we've
added 14 additional antibodies to the
base 30 marker panel in the max part
directing and profiling assay to look at
a 44 marker panel we actually use these
14 additional markers to incorporate 27
additional measurements into the
path Center report using max bar paths
error we can also look at the relative
expression levels of each of these
markers as can be visualized in Sensei
plots or even in cell progression plots
for a more quantifiable analysis and
scientifically we also observed data
that was already in alignment with
what's already being published for
example increased frequencies of ops for
the expression on cd4 t-cells in ppm see
samples from rheumatoid arthritis
samples collectively we've demonstrated
the flexibility of this xxx panel max
prior direct immune profiling assets
really accommodate expanded additional
markers expanded panels which will
really further facilitate of deep immune
profiling studies I'd like to invite you
to download the post the poster at our
booth and take a closer look at the data
we've shared with you and to see how the
max far directing and profiling assay
will be applicable to your particular
research questions with that I would
like to thank you for your interest in
our work thank you